hey 42 here no matter how good you are
at your job sooner or later you'll have
a bad day at the office you'll mess up a
presentation accidentally hit on your
Boss's Daughter or forget to go on mute
when you put the Telly on during a zoom
call whatever it is the consequences are
usually fairly minor you'll have to
spend 10 minutes on the naughty step
your boss assaults you with a stapler
that sort of
thing but then there are some jobs where
a bad day at work can be the difference
between life and death death on the 18th
of September 2012 a British man called
Chris lemons had one of the worst bad
days at the office in history it started
fairly normally but ended with Chris
lying on the bottom of the North Sea
with 5 minutes of bable air left in his
emergency tanks being 90 M deep there
was no way to swim to the surface and
whilst help was on the way his Rescuers
wouldn't show up for more than 35
minutes you don't need to to be a
mathematician to see that those numbers
added up to Chris being As Dead As the
Dead Sea except this video is not about
a deepsea tragedy quite the opposite
it's about one of the most incredible
survival stories I've ever come across
because despite spending more than 30
minutes at the bottom of the North Sea
with nothing to breathe Chris lemons is
still very much alive as for how well
that's a very good question but before I
answer it I just need to tell tell you
what the hell Chris was doing down there
in the first place and to do that I need
to introduce you to one of the most
hardcore professions known to M figure
skating oh no h gum wrong video one of
the most hardcore professions known to
man commercial saturation diving a job
so extreme almost nobody seems to know
it even exists let alone how it
works raid is a mobile game that is free
to play with millions of players and
over 80 million downloads already it's a
huge amount of fun and has incredible
Graphics my favorite part of the game is
collecting all the Champions there are
over 800 to collect and customize and
it's updated every month with tons of
bosses to take on now let's play a game
kiss Mary kill with raid Champions I'd
kiss Kalia for her warrior-like spirit
marry Queen Eva because he wouldn't want
to marry royalty right but I'd have to
say goodbye to ephos sorry and guess
what rage just brought him in the
Ultimate Warrior from the '90s zena
Warrior Princess complete with her sword
Whip and chakum you can recruit Zena
through the new Champion pass feature
with Zena as the ultimate reward you can
also summon her from ancient or sacred
shards drawing special summon boosts
every week between November the 10th and
January the 19th 2024 go check out Zena
warrior princess in game right now and a
special thanks to Universal Studios
licensing with all this exciting stuff
and more coming to raid if you haven't
started playing yet then what are you
waiting for click my link in the
description or scan my QR code to get
insane bonuses available only via my
link we're talking an epic Champion
knight erant from bannerlords faction
and other useful things like energy
refills skilled home and an XP booster
once you're in and you're crushing
enemies find me under the name 42 and if
you're fast enough you can join my clan
one of the biggest dangers in scuba
diving is something called decompression
sickness also known as the bends when
breathing pressurized stare at depth
gases like nitrogen are naturally
absorbed into body tissues as a diver
ascends at the end of a dive this
absorbed gas is released if he ascends
decompresses too fast the released gas
can form Tiny Bubbles in his tissues and
blood causing symptoms as mild as joint
pain and as severe as
death for recreational divers who follow
so-called no decompression dive profiles
the bendz is very rarely an issue but
recreational divers only go down to a
maximum of 40 m and usually much
shallower commercial divers on the other
hand work at depths of up to 300 M and
safely returning to the surface after
spending a prolonged period at that kind
of depth can take up to 2
weeks to put that into perspective
that's longer than it took the Apollo 11
astronauts to get back from the
Moon commercial saturation divers can
log hundreds of deep sea Dives per year
as they build and maintain oil and gas
infrastructure on the seabed but if they
have to spend days or weeks
decompressing after every dive that kind
of volume should be impossible right
well here's where modern technology
changes the game this space age
Contraption is what's known as a diving
chamber it's basically a very high-tech
living habitat with a very clever trick
up its sleeve the atmosphere inside can
be precisely adjusted to match the
pressures found on the ocean
floor the concept here is simple since
days or weeks of decompression after
every dive would be impractical just
don't decompress that in a nutshell is
saturation
diving during a stinted sea which
usually lasts for about 4 weeks
saturation divers will live inside a
pressurized Di diving chamber inside the
belly of a large
ship when it's time to dive they're
lowered to the ocean floor in a small
pressurized room called a diving
bell they do whatever it is they need to
do on the bottom then hop back into the
diving bell and up again to the diving
chamber throughout this whole process
the ambient pressure experienced by the
divers matches that found at the depth
they're working and since there's no
pressure change there's no risk of
decompression sickness in between
Dives it's an extremely clever system
that allows human divers to reach deep
sea infrastructure that would otherwise
be impossible to maintain in theory it's
brilliant but the reality is well it's a
bit crap for one thing working at these
depths and pressures is incredibly
physically demanding the divers will be
in the water every single day of a month
long operation with each dive lasting
about 6 hours unless you can run a sub
three hour marathon whilst wearing a fat
suit or crack coconuts between your bare
ass cheeks you probably aren't fit
enough to be a saturation diver then
there's the living conditions the divers
are housed in what is basically a tiny
prison cell with air pressures higher
than those found in a bicycle tire
there's no privacy no time off no
alcohol there isn't even any sunlight
the divers do do have access to the
internet and can speak to their loved
ones on the phone but most rarely call
home and for good reason the gas inside
the diving chamber is something called
helos a mixture of helium and oxygen the
same stuff they breathe during a dive if
you've ever inhal the contents of a
helium balloon you'll know it gives you
a hilarious cartoon-like voice for a few
seconds inside a diving chamber
saturation drivers have that same
suddenly not quite so hilarious voice
for a month straight and that month is
very much
non-negotiable this is the that I'm
currently
at at the kind of depths at which
commercial saturation divers typically
operate the bz is almost certain to be
fatal leave the chamber prematurely and
you're dead
it doesn't matter what happens in the
outside world your partner could die
your house could burn down aliens might
invade planet Earth you cannot leave
it's like being on Big Brother except
you get to keep your dignity so yeah
commercial saturation diving is brutally
demanding the claustrophobic living
conditions are like some kind of
elaborate practical joke and if anything
goes wrong you're
which brings me neatly back to
Chris
lemons in September 2012 he was one of a
dozen saturation divers working from a
ship called the Biby topaz in the North
Sea 125 m east of
abedine Chris was on a Freeman team with
Dave yasa and Duncan alock as per
standard safety protocols only two of
the divers were ever in the water at the
same time on the 18th of September 2012
it was Chris and Dave with Duncan
hanging back in the diving bell
as to so-called Bellman it was Duncan's
job to prepare the divers and look after
their gear particularly they're
umbilicals caike teers that feed the
divers gas hot water and power when
they're in the water the umbilicals also
allow for real-time communication
between the divers and the
ship the job that day was to replace a
section of pipe and carry out a few
basic checks inside a large underwater
structure called a manifold it it was
about as routine as things get in the
world of commercial saturation diving
with the only minor concern being the
weather on the surface where Winds of 40
mph were buffeting the bbby topaz and
whipping up 4 meter
waves not that that was such a big deal
bad weather in the North Sea is a bit
like vomit on the pavement outside your
local pub it's inevitable ships like BBY
topaz are built to deal with it thanks
to a neat piece of Kit called a dynamic
position ing system or DPS which is
essentially a kind of autopilot that
keeps the ship steady over a single spot
on the seabed even in rough
Seas Chris Dave and Duncan start a death
shift at about 900 p.m. that evening
descending in the diving bell before
Chris and Dave hopped out to get to work
inside the manifold to begin with
everything went according to plan but
about an hour into the dive an alarm
suddenly started blaring alarms are evil
little bastards at the best of times but
they're especially unwelcome when you're
199 M
underwater instructions from the ship
above arrived within a few seconds and
they did nothing to calm anybody's
nerves Chris and Dave were told to get
the hell out of there as fast as
possible the divers reacted instantly
climbing first to the top of the
manifold then using their umbilicals
like rope to get up to the diving bell
Dave made it there safely but Chris's
umbilical had looped itself around the
straight piece of pipe on top of the
manifold he tried to untangle himself
but to his horror the umbilical wouldn't
budge it was growing tort in his hands
the material groaning audibly as
detention
increased that shouldn't have been
possible there was always plenty of
slack in the
umbilicals unless suddenly Chris
realized exactly what must be happening
90 m above his head the bbby topaz was
drifting and if the ship was drifting
that meant Chris had just become the
anchor you probably don't need me to
tell you this but human beings do not
make very good anchors we just don't
have the metal for it as to bbby Topaz
drifted further from the dive site
Chris's umbilical grew even tighter
until all of a sudden it
snapped throwing him clear off the
manifold short of being eaten by a
megler on it was just about the worst
situation he could possibly have found
himself in his suit was equipped with
about 5 minutes of emergency gas but if
he didn't get back to the diving bell
before it ran out he was
dead the first thing he had to do was
get to the manifold but there was a
problem actually they were free when
Chris's umbilical snapped he didn't only
lose his supply of oxygen he also lost
his power hot water and coms no power
meant no light no hot water meant no
protection from the ambient water
temperature of about 4° C and no calms
meant there was no one to tell him just
what the hell was going on in other
words Chris was totally alone in Pitch
darkness in freezing cold water 90 MERS
beneath the surface of the North Sea he'
found himself in the world's most
horrific escape room where there were
only 5 minutes to solve all of the
puzzles and failure meant certain
death with little of a choice Chris
picked himself up and just headed off in
a random Direction despite quite
literally not being able to see his own
hand in front of his face by some Min a
miracle he quickly found the manifold
and from there he somehow managed to
climb 11 m to the
Top by that point he done everything he
could to assist the rescue attempt he
knew well hoped was coming all that was
left to do now was wait that and triy to
breathe slowly it's hard to imagine what
Chris was going through in those moments
it had taken him around 3 minutes to
climb the manifold so he had at most a
couple of minutes of air left if someone
was coming to rescue him he'd see their
lights long before he saw them but the
darkness was
absolute as the precious seconds ticked
by and it became harder to breathe he
knew with absolute certainty that he was
about to die not many people get such a
good long look at the Grim Reaper before
he swings his
Scythe meanwhile 90 M straight up well
not straight up that was kind of the
whole bloody problem meanwhile somewhere
vaguely overhead the crew of the BBY
topaz were in the middle of a fulls
scale emergency the dynamic positioning
system had suffered a catastrophic
failure and despite frantic efforts to
fix it it remained about as responsive
as a 4-we old corpse without the DPS the
ship was at the mercy of the Towering
waves and 40 m hour winds and it was
drifting further away from Chris's
position by the
second hadn't so much hit the fan
as completely buried it one small piece
of good news was that the BBY topaz was
equipped with an ROV a small submersible
with a front-facing camera that could be
operated remotely from the ship so
whilst the crew wrestled with the DPS
the ROV was dispatched to the dive site
to try and locate Chris it arrived 16
minutes after the accident meaning Chris
had been without oxygen for
approximately 11
minutes the footage recorded by the RV's
camera that night relayed live to the
ship is well it's difficult to watch
Chris was lying on his side on the top
of the manifold you might think he would
have been deathly still but he wasn't he
was twitching his arms hands and legs
jerking at random he was slowly
suffocating to
death dive ships like the baby topas
have large Crews and close to a 100
people gathered to watch the feed from
the
ROV it must have been a Haring
experience these men and women stood
less than 200 M from where Chris lay but
he might as well have been on the
International Space Station for all they
could do to help was stands there and
watch his their friend slowly died as
the minutes ticked by Chris is twitching
slowed and eventually
stopped nobody was giving up but it was
clear that this was no longer a rescue
operation it was a mission to recover
the
body approximately 28 minutes after the
accident the DPS suddenly flickered back
into life the crew immediately set a
course for the dive site and Dave yasa
who had stayed in the water beneath the
diving bell prepared himself mentally
and physically for what was to come
next
a few minutes later the BBY topaz was
back over the manifold and Dave made his
move working as fast as he could he
clipped himself to the body and somehow
hauled himself back up his own umbilical
and onto the staging area beneath the
dive
Bell then he attached Chris's body to a
recovery system which pulled it
inside waiting there was belman Duncan
allcock and he wasted no time tearing
off Chris's helmet his entire head was
bright blue and cold to the touch he was
obviously dead but Duncan had to at
least try it's impossible to know
exactly when Chris's Air Supply ran out
but assuming the emergency tank lasted
the estimated 5 minutes it was supposed
to at this point Chris had taken his
last breath approximately 31 minutes
earlier Duncan forced two deep lung
fulls of air into Chris's mouth and then
something incredible happened after half
an hour of lying alone on the bottom of
the North Sea Chris lemons
breathed a few seconds later he pulled
himself fully into the diving bell and
sat down in his usual seat apparently
unharmed if you're hoping I'm about to
explain how this apparent miracle
happened I'm afraid you're out of look
because the truth is nobody knows for
sure by All rights Chris lemons should
be dead when the brain is deprived of
oxygen irreversible brain damage usually
usually sets in at around the 4minute
mark with death following a couple of
minutes after that Chris went over half
an hour without oxygen but so far as
anyone can tell he suffered no ill
effects
whatsoever the best theory anyone's come
up with so far as to how that's possible
is that two elements of the accident
worked in Chris's favor the first was
the cold the moment Chris's suit lost
its hot water supply his body was
exposed to the 4° cus Waters of the
North Sea that's about the temperature
of your average ice bath as he laid
there on the top of the manifold after
losing Consciousness his body began to
cool rapidly this sudden drop in
temperature would have dramatically
slowed Chris's metabolic processes
reducing his oxygen
consumption the second Factor was the
gas mix he was breathing Helios contains
a higher partial pressure of oxygen than
the air we breathe up here on the
surface and Chris hadn't just been
breathing it during the dive he'd been
living in a diving chamber full of the
stuff for for weeks as a result Chris's
tissues would have been more highly
saturated with oxygen than a regular
person meaning he had more stores to
draw upon as the breathless minutes
ticked
by put those two things together and we
can at least get somewhere close towards
understanding what happens that day deep
sea saturation diving is one of the most
extreme jobs on Earth and it takes a
special kind of person to be able to
face the unique challenges it brings to
give you an idea of just how special
Chris is let me tell you what happens
next after the incident the BB topaz
headed straight back to abedine for
debriefing after 4 days decompressing
the divers emerged from the diving
chamber so doctors could give them a
full checkup after they convinced
themselves that Chris wasn't some kind
of zombie merman they gave him two
choices he could take some time off to
process what had happened or he could
get back out there Chris had just come
within a whisker of dying in one of the
the scariest loneliest ways imaginable
and yet he didn't consider quitting even
for an instant just 3 weeks after the
accident he Dave yasa and Duncan oock
were back on the bottom of the North Sea
choosing to continue his career as a
saturation diver was an incredibly Brave
move but Chris went one step further on
his very first dive after the incident
along with Dave and Duncan he returned
to the very same manifold that had
almost be become his
to they'd gone back to finish the
job thanks for
watching don't forget to use my rage
Shadow Legends Link in the description
or scan my QR code to get insane bonuses
for new players with an epic champion
and thanks again to R Shadow Legends for
sponsoring this video